[Applause]
armed assailants on roads and highways
stop drivers to rob them gangs of young
men and women force people out of their
cars to steal their vehicles in broad
daylight at least breaking down doors
looking for culprits this isn't new but
since Kovach 19 and lockdowns arrived in
chile people say they feel less safe
24-year old Erik ellinghouse and
recently became one of the latest
statistics while walking home from work
through this park about asking people
Akina a guy appeared with a face mask
like we all wear now and pointed a gun
at my head give it to me give it to me
he shouted I was in too much shock to
react until he threatened to fire the
gun then I gave him my mobile phone
muggings have increased all over the
capital Santiago drug traffickers are
hiring deliveryman to transport drugs
instead of fast food because they're
allowed to operate during quarantine but
organized crime is making far more
sinister inroads especially in Chile's
poorest areas tena runs one of at least
70 soup kitchens that have sprung up in
Lapine tanah a municipality where kovat
infections are soaring as fast as
unemployment many here have been out of
work for at least two months a community
organizer helps raise donations to
provide 200 lunches a day but in many
poor income neighborhoods authorities
say that there is growing evidence which
has been confirmed to us by some locals
who declined to be on camera that
organized crime is now beginning to try
to play the role of Robin Hood they're
doing this by giving away food or
financing some of these soup kitchens in
a bid to win over the hearts and minds
or at least the loyalty of people in
desperate need lapping tennis mayor says
they also want to win the locals silence
what I've seen is that they're giving
away food to people who are infected
with Kove at 19 and they use the social
networks to publicize what they're doing
the director of public security and
order tells us police are responding to
the crime wave
installing hundreds of new cameras and
drones to gather intelligence in real
time back home during quarantine and
curfew it's more complex for the common
delinquent to carry out traditional
crimes so they're resorting to more
serious crimes and that generates more
violence
indeed criminals here are becoming
increasingly bold which raises another
concern that in times like these of deep
recession and need many could be tempted
to believe that resorting to crime is
justifiable when you have a family to
feed to see inhuman al Jazeera Santiago